so let let's just get right into the
speech and and uh make some observations
about both the style and substance of
what he's saying so we'll we'll first
run um his opening
statement today I am present to inform
you that the Western world is facing a
significant
threat it is in danger because those who
are supposed to defend the values of the
western world are co-opted by a
worldview that inevitably leads to
socialism and consequently to poverty
and economic
deprivation
unfortunately like you said this this uh
and I should have mentioned this at the
top we are running a these clips are
actually an AI translated version of mle
that is meant to sound to approximate
the tenor of M's voice so some clever
person ran the trans script through one
of these AI voice generators and uh
created this you know appro this this AI
approximation of mle's voice and that it
actually SNS his mouth to uh read the
word so this is a weird you know uh 2024
thing that we're doing here I just
wanted to disclaim that uh as as loudly
and forcefully as possible and mention
that as always we will link to our
sources uh and the original trans script
uh that you you can watch uh to but we
we did check and you know it's it's it's
accurate with the transcript that the WF
uh posted but we just thought for audio
and video purposes this would be like
the best way to consume this uh that
aside uh his opener there really is like
you said Marcos consistent with the
message we've heard over and over again
which is that there this is uh kind of
an existential battle between um
individualism and collectivism in all
its forms um anyone weigh in there
before we continue yeah no I just wanted
to say I think um if I'm not mistaken I
think Malay was photographed uh as he
was entering the plane that took him to
Davos with a copy of individualism and
economic order by freed haek um so I
think that tells you you know about the
the spirit that he wanted to convey with
that speech and he did
absolutely Liz anything else where you
want to keep going let's go I need more
M all right let's go in recent decades
motivated by some well-intentioned
desires to help others and others by the
desire to belong to a privileged cast
the main leaders of the western world
have abandoned the model of freedom for
different versions of what we call
collectivism we are here to tell you
that collectivist experiments are never
the solution to the problems that
afflict the citizens of the world but
rather they are their
cause trust me there is no one better
than us argentines to provide testimony
on these two
issues
when when we embrac freedom in 1860 in
35 years we became the world's first
dominant power 35 years we became the
first world power while when we embraced
collect activism over the past 100 years
we saw how our citizens began to
systematically impoverish themselves
until they fell to the 140th position in
the world 40 in the world but before we
can have this discussion it would be
important for us to First Look at the
data that supports why free market
capitalism is not only a possible system
to end World poverty but also the only
morally desirable system to achieve it
okay so he's saying that the Arc of
Argentina's history there is sort of a a
case study in what happens when you
Embrace and turn away from free market
capitalism would you be able to flesh
out a little bit of that political and
uh economic history for us marus marus
just give us the last like 200 years of
like your country
yeah minutes in like in like two minutes
right great thank you well but but mle
is right in that Argentina is a a sadly
remarkable example of what happens when
you uh steer away from capitalism and
free markets uh
Argentina um back in the in the late n
in the late 19th century was among the
top economies of the world um it was
second only to the US um in terms of the
countries that received the most
immigrants uh Millions ions and millions
of Europeans basically but also people
from um from Asia came to Argentina
during that time among them my own
ancestors from Italy and the ancestors
of basically all of us who live here
today uh because this was a country
where you could Thrive you know where
you could uh just you know buy a piece
of land and and and work your way uh
towards the middle class and get
yourself a home and buy yourself a home
uh get a stable job and and be able to
save and and this is because Argentina
was a country that was open to the world
uh where trade international trade was
very important this was a country where
um restrictions to to economic
activities were were low uh there wasn't
a lot of uh corporate
corporatism um the the the role of the
state was very limited uh public
spending was not uh super high we had no
sense Central Bank we had no inflation
um and we just basically welcomed anyone
who would want to come to Argentina and
live here peacefully um beginning
in that stick out to me about
Argentina's origin story is it seems
like on the note that you're hitting
there there were also you know have been
for a long time these like little ethnic
enclaves you know with so much
immigration comes yes some amount of
assimilation and and becoming Argentine
but also at the same time sometimes
little communities of expats and there
are still these little towns in
Argentina where people speak entirely
Italian or entirely German or entirely
French or what have you and I think
there's an interesting correct me at any
point if I'm wrong but I think that
that's a really interesting thing and
then also Argentina used to be pretty
like natural resource Rich right with a
lot of Agriculture and just like so much
to export is that correct correct okay
that's correct uh in terms of um of
assimilation I would say that the you
know you having towns where people speak
language different than Spanish that's
not something that you will find today
you could find that at the beginning of
the 20th century for sure and you can
find towns today um where you know the
the last names of everyone will be
German or you know Italian or or Spanish
will see correct or or vice you know
like Zachs um or or you will find you
know architecture that is entirely
Bavarian uh you know that's that's
actually Vish where the October Fest is
held of course um you you will find
ethnic en clubs like that but the
country um but people assimilated pretty
well I wouldn't say that there were U
you know communities that were left out
or that decided to stay out on purpose
uh but but they they assimilated pretty
well but the the the main problem begins
with the with the Great Depression and
then uh in the 19 40s with the rise of
fascism because if you think about it
Argentina is the only country in the
world were 80 years after the downfall
of Nazism and fascism there is still a
very popular fascist party because Juan
Pon was a general in the Army in the
Argentinian Army he studied under
musolini he traveled to Italy while he
uh was president and and basically in uh
put in place the same corporatist model
uh fascist model uh to manage the
country's economy right and so this is
the time where free enterprise
capitalism started to be left out
basically and this is a time where the
government stepped in and and and this
is a time where public spending Rose
where taxation Rose where many people
started fleeing you know and capital
started fleeing this was a trend that
was opposite what had happened in the
past say 60 or 70 years uh suddenly uh
people wanted to leave the country and
not come in uh Argentina stopped
receiving uh immigration basically um
and we started having a succession of
governments one after the other who
would fight uh because uh they claimed
that the the prior one had not been as
leftist as the new one right because
even the opposition embraced this
paranis model because pism was so
popular and it was popular because Pam
basically uh handed out uh all of the
the money that the country had you know
uh until there was none left and of
course there was also no incentives for
generating wealth you know because if
you're just going to confiscate it the
way he did with
nationalizations um and confiscations
and and and measures like that well of
course no one's going to no one's want
to want to give you anything in the
future um so yeah this is how Argentina
started falling in the indices of uh
economic freedom but also in terms of
GDP per capita for example because uh at
the beginning of the 20th century
Argentina was very similar to Australia
and Canada these these are two countries
that are also small in terms of
population they're also huge in terms of
you know the land that they have and but
the trajectories have been very very
different Australia and Canada are you
know part of the first world if you will
today they're rich Nations uh they have
their problems but they're nowhere as
similar as Argentina where we have a
poverty rate of about 50% so Argentina
is indeed a perfect example of what
happens when you when you basically
abandoned C capitalism and and libertar
and liberalism in in you know in the old
sense uh and so I'm glad that that mle
talked about this at DS hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcaster see
you next week